allo smith golder signori è arrivato il
momento di operare seriamente ma prima
sigla a chi no ma no a no
anat sud ma siamo su surgery games and
pensions and education che non in realtà
non è un gioco è un simulatore a
chirurgia dove ci sono un bel po di cose
che puoi fare ad esempio infilare i tubi
nell'anno gioisco ciao ciao già l'inizio
di sconti del 10
devo ammettere sedativo addirittura c'è
ed è anche gli infili subito il tubo ma
devo prima a sedare il paziente
se diamo il paziente nel senso
ammettiamolo seduto che poi non è un
casino
la paziente era sdraiato interesse a
populin fino alla siringa nella vena
divertentissimo anche gioco bello
proprio non so come ho fatto al gris nes
e deride numero bene purché tosco ad e
volubili ficcare il come si chiama
questo coso che infine avveniva tutto
pure lubrificato fantastico gioco
proprio hanno pensato a tutti i dettagli
kraft su youtube.com and education
subito allora ragazzi
perdonatemi se se può essere un po
triste questa barca wikilewaks comes out
però marcia qui venduto torneo open
source certo seri medico della comunque
la noi e degli illuminati ragazzi c'è
niente da fare
bene bene ha un look sweet tears forse
devo rimuovere questo coso che un nuovo
di alien va bene faccio io devo pure
medicarlo la madonna fantastico alabiso
di portare fuori fantastico e poi devi
rimasta una cosa ancora più brutta di
questa l'unica roba più brutta di questo
gioco e
e giocarli coop con pietro potrebbe
essere ancora più brutto ma peggio di
così è difficile che ci devi impegnare
non ecco un altro uomo di alieno same
way with di adra migliorerà all'infinito
questa roba ci dovrò fare questa cosa
continuamente basta devo pure tornare
indietro
e così grazie jeff bene abbiamo finito
la colonscopia sto facendo della mia
vita quello che ho sempre desiderato
detto questo ragazzi ci sono un sacco di
altre di e di altri di altre chirurgie
che possono praticare sui pazienti e non
ce n'è una che non mi faccia schifo
neanche una posso mettere silicone nelle
tette bene quello però non lo posso
mettere su youtube però quello che
infine un tubo nell'anno posso mettere
tutti insieme sono dei tutorial su come
eseguire dei trapianti insomma chirurgia
no e poi tra tutti questi c'è come
cucinare un tacchino
ma che cosa stramacchia centro per
rifare il retinal the tech mentali
surgery che non ho la più pallida idea è
sempre con dottor jeff bene grande
dottor jack tama ti prego dimmi che sei
tu il paziente nel trapianto di capelli
ti prego spiegare come ha fatto l'occhio
l'ho già studiato lo so dottor jet sono
pronto mi dica lei se vai vai all
patient dei 30 anni poi avere starò
esatto ma la donna sono ipocondriaco
come lo schifo adesso mi cavo in mano e
mi va bene faccio io questa la parte che
mi piace di che mi fa ve lo schifo
ragazzi che gli fa si potesse dare il
paziente questo e ancora lo so fare
anche con gli tub imparo a fare il
medico così il di laurea va bene allora
la prima cosa che facciamo è mettere le
gocce al nell'occhio che credo sia cioè
serve raga mi fa il professore carmelo
duro l'interact allora questo cosa serve
per aprirgli l'occhio tenerglielo aperto
tipo di film horror no dobbiamo fare io
non so che cosa sto facendo pneumatico
il retino plexi non so neanche cosa sia
di preciso prova click da siringa to
insert débat public space
ah ok sarebbe per dilatare a posso
toglierlo già la madonna già fatto io
potrei guidare io ho posto di figure
l'inter grigiastri surgelatore grazie io
per ringraziarla sa che cosa le faccio
dottore siccome il dottore è stato così
gentile con noi come ultimo test di oggi
direi di fare il trapianto di capelli
appunto al dottore andati uccisi ciao
susy ovviamente non se lo faccio al
dottore trapianto lei mi spiega come far
sì che lui è uguale piste si può fare
anche per la barba passaggio in via sono
a posto a devo prendere prima dei
capelli da un donatore e poi metterlo
dobbiamo farli prima luci campobello
shampoo antibatterico ragazzi che
grafica incredibile che gesto shampoo
click and drug devo fare tutto io mica
neanche in barbie c'erano ste cose
contini dal fascino incredibile che
possiamo lavare mamma mia ragazzi
veramente stato soddisfazione non sapevo
neanche lavando il cavallo di barbie
comunque io per il trapianto di barba un
po ci penserei esce adesso vediamo
disegniamo dove si deve mettere il
cappello nuovo no non era proprio quello
che volevo fare va bene ok dai ritmi
perfetto anche tunisia devo tagliare i
capelli ma come il trapianto di capelli
potrai questi sono i capelli del
donatore va bene a posto io comunque
raga non ho capito assolutamente il
perché devo fare lo shampoo al paziente
se gli devo mettere i capelli prego ti
prego click the indicato in gialal
estetico ok perfetto quindi adesso
trapianti ap rimaneste tiziano e poi
trapiantiamo va bene weekend e fucka
albergava che brutta roba sto facendo
oh mio dio li sto tagliando lo scalpo
beh almeno l'ho fatta a forma di faccina
de felice che schifo lo riesco e la
scrissi un tic tac tic tac è che
veramente orribile non facciamo che non
la guardiamo questa roba che mi fa
veramente schifo voi guardate me io
guardo voi ragazzi come procede la vita
la scuola atto a posto io un sacco bene
amo il mio lavoro quindi per antonio
conte qualcuno si e trapiantato dietro
la testa
quindi chi è che in sé tagliato lo
scalpo per antonio conte non so
veramente è la cosa più oscena che
abbiamo mai visto with the sec t shirt
che devo analizzare un'azione che devo
fare click dei follicoli è come tagliare
sushi la gara non cambia niente come
fare immaginatevi che immaginatevi come
se fossero nigiri all'estetismo il dotto
dottore l'ho fatto solo per lei è
veramente tra tutti quello che mi ha
fatto più schifo questo quindi se non
fosse per lei ai follicoli follicoli ci
hai visto trapani trapiantando cappello
per capello marche problemi sentire
truman station bene così ragazzi basta
raga io posso concludere qua ci sono un
sacco di altra roba che si poteva fare
ma per adesso passo poi magari piovana
adesso non segue il pometino che ti sale
ecco quello vero ragazzi che il video vi
sia piaciuto ricordatevi se avete
bisogno di capelli
io non sono una serie a è però il faccio
il trapianto quello che faccio quasi ai
ragazzi se vi è piaciuta lasciato
momento mi piace anche a rischio e non
ci vediamo a un possibile da ragazze
[Musica]